last night at our monologue we gave you
a retrospective on just why President
Trump was able to pull off a historic
victory in last year's presidential race
in case you missed it
well I called in a Fox News on election
night to detail what the 2016 election
was all about take you down memory lane
to me this was predictable but on the
other hand this is a a modern-day
political miracle you're witnessing
before your eyes right now and that is
to go up again everybody and all the
pundits and all the pollsters and all
the prognosticators out there and defy
all the odds and it's the American
people that have said enough is enough
they're tired of the corruption the
cesspool draining the swamp all of these
things were resonating you know when you
look at a state like Wisconsin what do
they think they want their jobs back
they want the labor participation rate
to be lower in other words more people
having jobs they want America to be
energy independent they're tired of a
horrible educational system the tired of
Obamacare rates going through the roof
this is not complicated what's happening
now is not working and these guys and
Donald Trump has gone out there and he
outwork Hillary Clinton and he put
forward a much better agenda and America
said enough is enough with failed policy
that's what this election was about
right in November of 2016 the failed
policies of President Obama were
actively hurting this country
remember economic growth was anemic
health care premiums that went through
the roof in spite all the promises
illegal illegal immigration was
impacting negatively communities all
across this country
taxes just too high On January 20th
President Trump was sworn into office
and immediately started the process to
keep his promises and fix these problems
but while the president has been moving
is what I call the speed of Trump
Congress Republicans they've been
dragging their feet the repeal and
replace of Obamacare died in the United
States Senate funding for the border
wall postponed some of it and now the
Senate is planning to fundamentally
alter president Trump's tax proposal we
learned earlier today the Senate plan
will delay the best part of it the
corporate tax cut until 2019
really now by the way there are 300
bills that the house is passed is that
the Senate hasn't even picked up their
nominees to the president's government
that haven't even been been confirmed at
this point if you're a member of
Congress and let's say you're watching
this from your second home in the DC
swamp in the DC sewer I want you to
listen very closely I do have a message
for you spineless Republicans if this
delay goes to 2019 it will be rightly
interpreted by the American people as a
failure of you doing your job on a
spectacular level these tax cuts are
crucial to American businesses these tax
cuts are crucial to getting good-paying
jobs from overseas there are Patriots of
money spurring the economy hopefully for
decades to come
so it's time for senators like Mitch
McConnell John McCain the others in the
Senate stop lecturing us the American
people it's time to get to work I know
you say the expectations have been too
high if this tax plan gets put off to
2019 you water this down this failure
will be on you the Republican party gets
trounced a year from now in the midterms
it won't be president Trump's fall not
gonna be my fault not gonna be talk
radio's Falls I'm gonna be the Fox News
Channel's fault it's gonna be your fault
because you didn't have the courage the
vision the backbone the spine the
identity the courage to put everything
on the line for the people you're
supposed to serve the great people of
this country the Forgotten men and women
of this country who this last election
was all about these are the people I
have spoke about for the past year on
food stamps out of the labor force in
poverty they're suffering they don't
have time to wait to 2019 those that are
having trouble buying their first home
those are the people you're supposed to
serve you're supposed to be public
servants one year from now if you lose
your majority in the House Senate most
specifically the Senate you'll have
nobody to blame but yourself and you
will all pay the price and you'll have
your colleagues pay the price at the
polls next year a year ago from a year
from now it'll be your fault
wake up
or go home that's my message best Sean
tick tock